these allegations that I have sent
inappropriate pictures over the Internet
are completely ridiculous
they are levied by my political rivals
who are trying to embarrass me and
advance their own agenda so let me be
perfectly clear these allegations are
false I will be vindicated TMZ has
obtained an actual photo of your
genitalia they're posting it to their
website as we speak they're saying you
took it how do you respond okay I may
have sent one photo of my genitalia
it was a one-time fit what about the new
report there are three new pictures
having been sent to three different
women
what second-rate news organization is
trying to York Times it was it was four
total no more you are sure that there
were only four photos sent that's it
four that's all there's no more than
four and how do you explain the one you
sent me please I'm begging you I'm
begging you to forgive me for the
foibles and transgressions
it was the reckless act of a younger man
a younger man you said you two seconds
before he stepped onstage that's very
last time I checked time is still real
okay so technically speaking I am much
older now than I was all of those
seconds ago
senator how are you even doing this
you